drew you're a very busy guy between this
is the second movie you've directed the
first was cabin in the woods
you wrote the Martian drew a chronicle
World War Z you're an exec producer on
the good place the Ted Danson succumb so
with all of the stuff that you have
going on in your professional life how
much of a long time coming was this
screenplay for you yeah I tend to I
didn't think about screenplays for a
long time well I'm working on other
stuff that's part of the process I think
I was I probably thought about this one
for a couple of years and I was doing
the Martian and I tend to think about
whatever's the opposite of whatever I'm
doing so the Martian was you know about
one character on a big planet and it was
spanned span across the globe the story
so this one I was very much about
ensemble casts one location dark crime
film might that wasn't intentional but I
the brain kind of wants to do the
opposite and so I was thinking about it
while I was working on the Martian and
and then around 2016 I decided okay it's
it's about time so I started writing and
what came first the character types or
the themes or the plot how did it all
come together yeah it's always so hard
with creativity but it's sort of it was
a few things it was I knew I wanted I
love the idea of just doing an ensemble
cast
III think I had I've been working on
something with a lot of previous and I
was lamenting to my wife I said my next
film it's just gonna be it's gonna be a
bunch of actors in a room talking I'm so
tired of visual effects and so I like
the idea of just starting him film where
everyone's checking into a hotel and
let's see where this takes us so that
was the basic idea and and sort of a
lifelong intoxication I would say with
crime cinema and crime fiction and
wanting to play around in that genre so
I had that first scene and then very
quickly the priest jumped out of me the
priest and the singer very much the the
twosome that you see walk out at the end
they were the two if the first two
characters in my mind I don't think that
was accidental there's something about
the
the spirituality and the artists you
know the of the the two characters there
that it sort of stuck with me and I kept
coming back to time and time again
why 1969 what did that time frame allow
you to do I guess it started with the
music honestly like I just I just loved
the music and I very quickly realized
that it was the movie was about the
music not just the songs on the
soundtrack but the act of making music
in difficult times and so for me I I
think I just happen to love the music of
the 60s but the reason I love it is big
it's not just because it's the
incredible it's that it's a reaction to
what was happening in the world and what
was happening in the world was this
incredible volatile political situation
and and the music was almost
revolutionary especially if you look at
the soul music you know a lot of the
songs I chose for Cynthia to sing
they're so poppy and infectious and fun
and then you listen to the lyrics and
they're heartbreaking they're
heartbreaking and lonely and that
juxtaposition has always been attractive
to me the idea that we find such
heartbreak but can can deliver it can
deliver our heartbreak in such a way
that is so catchy for lack of a better
word I always I always loved that and so
I think it started there I also just
happen to love the 60s there's just
something fun it's like okay you get to
direct a movie well what are the
fashions good to be let's go to the 60s
well what are the weather we want the
sets to look like let's their 60s
wallpaper it's just it just it happened
organically I've read articles and
interviews that you've given where you
talked about how you and your cast took
cuts and pay from what you were usually
making what were the conversations that
you had with this a level cast to let
them know that yes you couldn't pay them
as much but you would make it worth
their while I mean it's really it just
started with the script because it's not
like I'm a great salesman I'm not gonna
talk anyone into anything I could but I
can I can
send them the script and say here's
here's the script here's the part I
really believe in this I really believe
in what we're gonna do here and in order
to do this we can't be expensive I mean
Studios did I get it I'm a business
partner with them I don't I I want to
make this make sense and so you you have
to say to them look and I it starts with
me quite frankly it's like I love I'm
gonna take large giant pay cuts um I'll
put my money where my mouth is because I
believe in this and I think that that
that that works when you just have to
put your money where your mouth is and
and the truth is I think actors actors
love to act and they love art and
they're not they're not getting there
they're not making a lot of movies like
this right now and so I think they were
very excited to get to do all of those
things my favorite performance not to
play favorites but I will is Cynthia
Revo I'm such a huge fan of hers from
her stage work particularly color purple
where she won a Tony I feel like in
watching this movie who else could have
done that I mean I I don't know and I
don't think anyone and I sort of knew
how hard this part was gonna be to cast
but you just sort of barrel ahead and
and hope for the best but it was very
important to me that we sing live not
just cuz I don't like lip-syncing but
because to me as I mentioned the movies
about about the act of singing the act
of singing when no one knows you're
watching the idea that what does a
singer do when she's alone mmm I to me
that's that's what gets her through the
night and and so I knew in order to get
that we needed someone to sing live and
I knew we were gonna be very ambitious
with our camerawork so I needed someone
who could sing live over and over and
over and and and then the other tricky
part just to make my life even more
complicated as a director was that she
the character if Darlene is armored so
she never really because of what she's
been through she when she's talking
she's not she's not a moding she's
learned to be for to self protective her
emotions come out while she's singing
that's how she expresses her emotions so
I needed someone who could also
act and sing do all of this repeatedly
over and over and over and so we hoped
for the best but it was a really intense
casting process until Cynthia walk
through the door and then Cynthia walked
through the door and that was like the
heavens opened up and we went oh okay we
have a movie now because you just knew
it to shoot this second she started
singing everyone it's like with those
magical moments that you look for where
their hair grows up on the back your
neck and you go oh my god and lastly you
talked about how most the music that
Cynthia sings is kind of upbeat in in
sonically but lyrically sad what was
your process for kind of combing through
these classic mostly Motown songs and
picking them and what was it like to
present them all to Cynthia it was
really fun I mean she I mean she's just
she understood this character I think
she understood this this time sort of
inherently and so it was very much just
we talked a lot about just what the we
were as though it was a scene rather
than a song and this is the scene and
this is what the dialogue is and this is
this is what you're going through and
and approached it that way as opposed to
I go here's the song and here's the key
it was much more about let's talk about
the emotion that we're that we're going
through and let her and then she would
take it and find the key and find that
find the tempo to sort of match that's
the emotion ladies and gentlemen please
help me thank Adri daughter much for
coming graduation